Okay, so we spent a lot of time talking
about how to use hashing and, and the hmac
variant of hashing to make cookies that won't be
tampered with. Let's talk about using passwords for hashing. So,
say we have a table for users in our
database, and this table has a couple columns. One column
is for the user's name. And another column is
for the user's password. If we wanted to verify a,
a user is valid we might have a function that looks
like this. You know, and this would be called when somebody
logs in, and it problably say like, user, you know, equals
get user, where this is some function that gets the user
from the database. And then we'd say, you know, so if
this user exists and this user's password equals pw, what was
passed in, return user, and that's, and that's simple enough. Now,
the problem with this approach is that if your database gets
compromised, you are in trouble. You gave away all of
your users' passwords. Which means, not only are your users
angry, because you compromised their privacy your website is in
trouble, because you've got bad guys logging in, screwing around
with all people's accounts, because they know everybody's passwords. So
that's a really bad situation. So what we want to
do is, instead of storing these plain text passwords in
our database, we'll store a password hash in our database.
So we'll have h of hunter two and h of Metallica. And if our
database is compromised, all the attacker has is a bunch of a bunch of password
hashes, and you know, it's very, very
difficult, basically impossible, to turn the hash of
this into the actual input parameter. This
this function changes a little bit, so instead
of comparing pw to the password field in the database,
we compare hash of pw to the password hash in the
database. And all a sudden we're in a much better situation.
This takes very little work, and your database doesn't have any
plain text passwords in it. And if your database does get
compromised, all the attacker has is a bunch of hashes and
not a, not a bunch of valuable passwords. So, this is
a very important strategy that you should employ when building user
registration systems, such as on this week's homework
but before we get there, let's do a quiz.